good morning Hank it's Tuesday August
25th the day after my 32nd birthday
thank you so much for making my birthday
so awesome Hank I don't want to blow it
out of proportion but that video made me
happier than anything has ever made me I
mean the birthday wishes from all over
the world the burning of unicorns the
blender izing the songs the placing of
items on to the heads and the willy
cakes
oh man the willy cakes although you know
Hank Willy for all the love he gets from
nerdfighteria doesn't seem to love us
back enough I mean a Hank look what
Willy did to the great white wall of cow
it's now a great white two-legged
tailless wall of cow and it is with a
heavy heart that I report that Willy
also seems to have blinded the sock
puppet Hank your birthday present really
reminded me of why I love nerdfighteria
and also why I love the Internet
here's the amazing thing people didn't
make those songs and artwork and
pictures and video clips in order to
become famous or rich they did it to
quote William Faulkner not for glory and
least of all for profit but to create
out of the materials of the human spirit
something which did not exist before and
what I love most about the nerdfighter
community is when we come together to
make stuff with and for each other not
to make money not to get attention not
to gain subscribers but to make gifts
hey let me give you an example of what
I'm talking about that has nothing to do
with nerdfighteria sometimes I feel like
the Internet is just like flashy flashy
lights but then once in a while the
Internet like a team of a thousand
monkeys typing at a thousand typewriters
for a thousand years will make us
something magical I think you know what
I'm talking about Hank I'm talking about
Gary Busey family portrait I mean look
at it Hank just look at it do you think
the creator of Gary Busey family
portrait was thinking about getting rich
or getting famous as he laborious Lee
photoshopped pictures of Gary Busey into
a family portrait no he was thinking
geez I have a great idea and I'm gonna
do this well so that it will make people
happy and who knows maybe it will also
make Gary Busey realize that you know he
needs to make some different choices hey
every single day I get emails from
aspiring writers asking my advice about
how to become
writer and here's the only advice I can
give don't make stuff because you want
to make money it will never make you
enough money and don't make stuff
because you want to get famous because
you will never feel famous enough make
gifts for people and work hard on making
those gifts in the hope that those
people will notice and like the gifts
maybe they will notice how hard you
worked and maybe they won't and if they
don't notice I know it's frustrating but
ultimately that doesn't change anything
because your responsibility is not to
the people you're making the gift for
but to the gift itself and I just want
to say I got your gift
I liked it thank you three more things
one my book Paper Towns is nominated for
a teens top ten award if you are a teen
you can vote for it or other books if
you like them better link in the sidebar
- in the very near future I'm going to
break the question Tuesday world record
by answering 100 questions in four
minutes to do that I will need you to
leave many succinct questions in the
comments and three I have the distinct
honor of announcing the winner of global
geek week the winner is
Gus 23 who made a great video about geek
art which you can view in the sidebar
and who wins two tickets to fly anywhere
in the continental United States via
Virgin America the runner-up was a new
nerdfighter who goes by the username
Safa rune who made a great video that
you can also view in the sidebar but who
sadly doesn't win anything other than my
respect and admiration thanks to
everyone who helped make global geek
week such a success and thanks again
from an awesome birthday present
Hank I'll see you singing tomorrow